[Musik]
die Nachrichten des Tages heute mit
Mitri Sirin guten Abend in den nächsten
20 Minuten die wichtigsten Nachrichten
und sportliches gehört natürlich mit
Christin to dazu na viel Unruhe beim BVB
guten Abend wir starten mit einer
Einigung in die Sendung für die es Jahre
brauchte und die stark umstritten
ist EU einigt sich auf asylreform die
Einreise Regeln sollen verschärft werden
auch Haftzentren direkt an den
Außengrenzen sind
geplant leichtere Einbürgerung und
schnellere Abschiebungen die
ampelfraktionen verständigen sich auf
Änderungen bei den
[Musik]
migrationsregeln Abschied von einem
beliebten Sänger und Entertainer Gunther
Emmerlich stirbt im Alter von 79
Jahren nach einer gefühlt halben
Ewigkeit haben sich EU-Staaten und
Europaparlament auf eine gemeinsame
asylreform geeinigt ziel ist es die
nichtreguläre Migration nach Europa
einzudämmen es ist eine deutliche
kursverschärfung die massive Kritik
auslöst schauen wir zunächst auf das
Vorhaben geplant sind beschleunigte
Asylverfahren und Abschiebungen schon an
der EU Außengrenze für Menschen mit
geringer bleibbechance sie dürfen dabei
unter haftähnlichen Bedingungen
festgehalten werden auch Familien mit
Kindern und innerhalb der EU soll es
eine solidarische Verteilung von
Flüchtlingen geben wer keine aufnehmen
will kann sich mit 20 000 € pro Migrant
freikaufen über die umstrittene
asylreform Isabel
Schäfers das zielf Fest vor Augen konnte
heute ein jahrelanger Streit zur
Einigung gebracht
werden wir brauchten einen Kompromiss
der human und fair für die ist die
Schutz suchen der die ablehnt die keine
lgründe haben und der die bekämpft die
das Leid der Migranten ausnutzen das
haben wir hinbekommen bis zuletzt hatte
das Europaparlament sich für mehr
humanitäre Standards eingesetzt etwa die
Ausnahme von Familien mit Kindern aus
den neuen beschleunigten Asylverfahren
an den
eu-aßengrenzen das wollte auch
Deutschland doch die Position der
Mitgliedstaaten war festgefahren
Kompromisse nur begrenzt möglich wichtig
war aber dass wir die Mehrheiten
insgesamt behalten und das war ein sehr
fragiles Gerüst und wir haben immer
gesagt am Ende müssen wir zustimmen weil
es muss eine europäische Lösung geben um
Kommunen dauerhaft zu entlasten dass die
beschlossenen Maßnahmen diese erhoffte
Entlastung tatsächlich bringen
bezweifeln viele Kritiker dafür hülten
sie die Menschlichkeit in Europa aus wir
fürchten dass wir die schlechtesten
Aspekte der letzten Jahre halt
weitersehen werden das heißt auch Tote
im Mittelmeer das heißt brutale
pushbacks an den Außengrenzen das heißt
eben gerade auch Haftzentren an den
Außengrenzen wo keine fern verfahren
möglich sind außerdem brauche es weitere
Anstrengungen etwa um abgelehnte
Asylbewerber tatsächlich rückführen zu
können wie Abkommen mit sogenannten
sicheren Drittstaaten doch diese
Abkommen sind schwer umzusetzen für die
meisten hier zählen heute weniger die
Details viele hatten im Vorfeld die
Sorge geäußert dass eine nichtteinigung
für einen Aufschwung der
Rechtspopulisten bei der Europawahl
sorgen könnte und so ist die Botschaft
für die meisten hier heute schlicht
Europa hat sich geeinigt im jahrelangen
migrationsstreit auch wenn das Ergebnis
im Einzelnen die meisten nicht
zufriedenstellt und tatsächlich hat sich
auch die Bundesregierung nach langen
Verhandlungen auf neue migrationsregeln
geeinigt dabei geht's um schnellere
Einbürgerungen und erleichterte
Abschiebungen so soll der
ausreisegewahrsam von 10 auf 28 Tage
verlängert werden auf der anderen Seite
wird die Frist zur Einbürgerung verkürzt
von 8 auf 5 Jahre in besonderen Fällen
auf 3 Jahre JRE und die beiden Aspekte
die wollen wir jetzt weiter vertiefen
mit schakuntala benergy in Berlin
shakuntala zuerst zum Thema
Einbürgerungen was wurde beschlossen da
geht's erstmal um Verbesserungen für
diejenigen die hier leben arbeiten und
Steuern zahlen die sollen nicht mehr 8
Jahre warten müssen auf eine
Einbürgerung sondern nur noch 5 Jahre
und in besonders vielvprechenden Fällen
sogar nur noch 3 Jahre sie dürfen dann
außerdem ihre Staatsbürgerschaft künftig
behalten also doppelte
Staatsbürgerschaft wird dann regelmäßig
möglich sein ähm man hatte sich im
Vorfeld noch darüber gestritten wieer
sie Voraussetzungen sind es geht um den
Lebensunterhalt den muss jetzt jeder der
sich einbürgern lassen will selber
bestreiten können aber es gibt eine
härtfallklausel für diejenigen die das
aus die das unverschuldetermaßen nicht
können das sind z.B kinderrentner aber
auch Menschen mit Einschränkungen darauf
hat sich die Ampel jetzt geeinigt sch
huntaler die Ampel hat auch gestritten
über rückführungsverbesserungen wie sie
es nennt worauf konnte man sich am Ende
einigen da hat man sich geeinigt auf
Verschärfungen mit den den en mehr
Abschiebungen und schnellere
Abschiebungen möglich werden sollten
sollten unter anderem darauf dass man
die ausreisepflichtigen länger
festhalten kann damit möchte man das
Untertauchen verhindern wenn die Leute
abgeholt werden dann darf in zukünftig
in Gemeinschaftsunterkünften unter
anderem auch in anderen Zimmern als dem
Zimmer des abzuholenden nachgeschaut
werden das sind praxisnahe Veränderungen
wie sie sich unter anderem die
Bundesländer gewünscht haben und zu dem
Gesamtpaket gehören auch Veränderungen
bei den Hilfsleistung für Asylbewerber
die sollen künftig erst nach 36 Monaten
und nicht schon nach 18 Monaten ähnlich
wie die Sozialhilfe gezahlt werden alles
in allem eine Verschärfung der Gangart
die die Ampel da heute beschlossen hat
und das ganze soll dann im Januar durch
den Bundestag danke für die Einschätzung
schakuntala jetzt zum stark umstrittenen
Haushalt für 2024 der wurde dem
Bundeskabinett heute vorgelegt
Beschlüsse gab's aber nicht zuletzt
wurde ja innerhalb der Ampel die
Einigung teilweise wie wieder in Frage
gestellt etwa der Förderstopp für die
Landwirte und die sind nach wie vor
stocksauer über den vorläufigen
Höhepunkt einer Hängepartie Christiane
hübscher die Einfahrt des weserunnels
bei Bremerhafen am Morgen blockiert von
einer traktorkolonne die Landwirte
protestieren weiter gegen das geplante
aus für Steuervergünstigungen im
Agrarbereich und drohen bereits mit noch
größeren Blockaden ich denke das ist nur
ein kleiner Vorgeschmack D drauf was am
8 Januar passieren wird wenn die
Bundesregierung da nicht LT und ja ihre
Pläne noch mal überdenkt und
überarbeitet auch
Landwirtschaftsminister ödemir Streit
dem Kabinett erneut gegen die
agrarkürzungen hinter den Kulissen wird
offenbar weiter verhandelt die Regierung
nimmt den neuen Haushalt nur zur
Kenntnis beschließt ihn aber nicht
ungewöhnlich findet die Union das ist
eine fakeaktion es sollte ja Eindruck
erweckt werden heute man sei jetzt
wirklich weiter gekommen man sei
konkreter geworden tatsächlich ist nicht
NS wirklich beschlossen worden und so
könnte dieser lange diskutierte Haushalt
Anfang Januar vom Bundestag erneut
verändert werden das ist auch das
Selbstverständnis des des Parlaments
dass der Haushalt vom Parlament gemacht
wird beschlossen wird und D deswegen
diese Fragen auch noch mal gestellt
werden aber wir werden nicht im großen
Stil dieses Paket aufschnüren können
jeder und jeder wird die geplanten
Kürzungen spüren wenn der CO2 Preis
steigt die plastikabgabe von den
Unternehmen auf die gelegt wird und
Flugtickets teurer werden die Maßnahmen
um das Loch im Bundeshaushalt zu
schließen die dürfen die
Verbraucherpreise im Januar
schätzungsweise um 0,7% erhöhen die
Inflation dürfte damit zum Jahresanfang
wieder auf etwa 4% steigen so die
Ökonomen wir bleiben bei Finanzen die EU
hatte ja während der coronapandemie ihre
Schuldenregeln ausgesetzt die
maastdrichtkriterien sehen unter anderem
vor dass die jährliche ne Verschuldung
nicht über 3% des
bruttoinnenlandsproduktes liegen darf
nach langem Streit haben sich die
Mitgliedsländer jetzt auf eine Reform
geeinigt die Grundlage hatten gestern
Bundesfinanzminister Lindner und sein
französischer Kollege leer bei einem
überraschenden Treffen in Paris gelegt
Frankreich und Deutschland vertraten bis
dahin ganz unterschiedliche
Positionen wir gehen nach Brüssel zu
Gunar Krüger Gunner jetzt also die
Einigung die alten maastrichtreeln sind
bald Geschichte was kommt da auf uns zu
nun da kommen neue Regeln für die
Haushalte in den EU Mitgliedstaaten auf
und zu die letzte Krise die hatte ja
zwei leeren parat zum einen die Schulden
sind zu hoch die Defizite sind zu hoch
die Staaten müssen runter von ihren
hohen Schuldenbergen zum anderen hat man
aber auch gesehen dass die bisherigen
starren Regeln dafür gesorgt haben dass
manche Mitgliedstaaten noch weiter in
die Schuldenfalle hineingetrieben wurden
und darum gibt es jetzt zwei Neuerung
zum einen bekommt die EU-Kommission hier
ein bisschen mehr macht sie darf Zukunft
die Schulden auf ihre Tragfähigkeit
prüfen sie muss garantieren dass in die
Zukunft investiert wird also in die
Digitalisierung in die Grün in den
grünen umbauen der Wirtschaft oder auch
in die Sicherheit von Europa aber weil
manche dem nicht trauen gibt es eine
weitere Neuerung das ist eine
Sicherheitslinie die dafür sorgt dass
besonders hochverschuldete Staaten ein
Mindestmaß an Schulden in jedem Jahr
abbauen müssen also unterm Strich etwas
flexiblere Regeln etwas weniger strenge
Regeln dafür sollen sie aber auch mal
angewendet werden und wenn das wirklich
passiert dann hält der Pakt was sein
Name verspricht nämlich Stabilität und
Wachstum live aus Brüssel Gunner Krüger
vielen
Dank wegen der schwächelnden Wirtschaft
in Deutschland ist der Energieverbrauch
in diesem Jahr um fast 8% gesunken das
hat die Arbeitsgemeinschaft
Energiebilanzen berechnet vor allem in
der energieintensiven Produktion sei ein
deutlicher Rückgang zu spüren der zeige
sich auch beim Verbrauch fossiler
Brennstoffe die Stromproduktion aus
erneuerbaren Energien habe hin gegen
zugenommen die Staatsanwaltschaft
Ingolstadt hat Ermittlungen wegen eines
vermeintlichen Anschlags auf AFD Chef
kropalla eingestellt kropalla hatte im
Oktober eine Wahlkampfveranstaltung
Ingolstadt abgebrochen er sei in den
rechten Arm gestochen worden erklärte
der afdchef der über Schwindel und
Schmerzen klagte im Krankenhaus wurde
ein Einstich aber keine Vergiftung
festgestellt die Staatsanwaltschaft
erklärte jetzt die Ermittlungen hätten
keine Hinweise auf eine Straftat oder
Täter ergeben kopala kritisierte die
Einstellung des
Verfahrens und jetzt zu Alexei navalni
der russische Oppositionspolitiker ist
seit Wochen aus seiner Lagerhaft
verschwunden auch die US-Regierung ist
darüber hoch besorgt und forderte den
Kremmel heute auf den 47-Jährigen
unverzüglich freizulassen navalni ist
für den Kremmel so etwas wie der
Staatsfeind Nummer 1 als Führer der
russischen Opposition forderte er immer
wieder Vladimir Putin heraus wurde
mehrfach verhaftet und überlebte einen
Giftanschlag aktuell verbüstete eine
19jährige Haftstrafe Sebastian m geht
auf
Spurensuche wo ist navalni diese Frage
stellen seine Unterstützer auf der
ganzen Welt auf Social Media seine
Sprecherin Kira Jarmusch ist selbst in
Gefahr wir sprechen mit ihr in einem
unbekannten Ort im
Exil sie haben es sich zur Aufgabe
gemacht ih zu verstecken vorerst
zumindest für die aktuelle Zeit des
Präsidentschaftswahlkampfs zu isolieren
dass er seine Anhänger nicht gegen Putin
organisiert und
mobilisiert alex nawalni ist Putins
gefährlichster innenpolitischer Gegner
er hat bereits bewiesen dass er die
Russen mobilisieren kann viele
unterstützen ihn im Land und im Exil
seit di Jahren sitzt er im Gefängnis
weggesperrt zuletzt in dieser
Strafkolonie 250 km entfernt von Moskau
aus der er jetzt verschwunden ist die HA
Bedingungen waren laut seinem Team
katastrophal jetzt sei er angeblich in
ein anderes Straflager verlegt worden
doch niemand weiß ob das stimmt Olga
ramanova kennt das russische
Gefängnissystem mit ihrer Organisation
Russland hinter Gittern kümmert sie sich
um die Rechte Tausender Insassen sie ist
in großer Sorge um
navalni wir können niemals wissen was
dort vor sich geht die Geschlossenheit
erlaubt es schwere Verbrechen zu begehen
sie können navalni verstecken sie können
ihn töten vergewaltigen und
vielleicht werden wir nie etwas davon
erfahren auch nicht wenn er das alles
nicht
überlebt navalnis Team rechnet nicht
damit dass er bald auftaucht die Wahlen
in Russland sind erst am 17 März
Wladimir Putin könnte ihn bis dahin
mundtot machen
wollen auf der anderen Seite des Teichs
bleiben Donald Trump und die Justiz ein
Dauerthema jetzt hat ihn das Oberste
Gericht des US-Bundesstaates Colorado
von der Vorwahl der Republikaner
ausgeschlossen die Richter berufen sich
auf einen Zusatz zur Verfassung der
besagt so das Gericht dass niemand
kandidieren darf der im Amt zu einem
Aufstand aufgerufen hat und so bewertet
es Trumps Rolle beim Sturm aufs Kapitol
in weiteren Bundesstaaten gibt es
ähnliche Klagen und jetzt muss wohl der
Oberste Gerichtshof
entscheiden nach dem schweren Erdbeben
in China ist die Zahl der Opfer weiter
gestiegen die Behörden melden jetzt
134 tote 10 000 Menschen haben ja zu
Hause verloren und mussten die zweite
Nacht bei eisigen Temperaturen
überstehen zahlreiche Zelte und andere
Hilfsgüter wurden in die abgelegene
Region im Nordwesten des Landes gebracht
war das schwerste Erdbeben in China seit
Jahren der erste Frankfurter Auschwitz
Prozess er beginnt erst gut 18 Jahre
nach Kriegsende und wird das größte
Strafverfahren der Nachkriegszeit auf
der Anklagebank 22 eh malige SS-Männer
erst als ihre grultaten aus dem
Konzentrationslager öffentlich
ausgebreitet werden beginnen viele
Deutsche über die Nazizeit nachzudenken
der industriell organisierte Mord an den
Juden rückt ins gesellschaftliche
Bewusstsein Isabelle de
laweger das sind sie die 22 Angeklagten
der Frankfurter
auschwitzprzesse Apotheker Ärzte und
Kaufleute die bis dahin unbehelligt im
Nachkriegsdeutschland gelebt hatten sie
geben sich selbstbewusst und waren an
einem der größten Verbrechen der
deutschen Geschichte beteiligt fast 20
Jahre nach Kriegsende markieren die
Prozesse einen
Wendepunkt dass hier wirklich einer
breiten Öffentlichkeit diese Verbrechen
erstmals bekannt geworden sind und Z
Tage trat das arbeitsteilig organisierte
Prinzip der Massenvernichtung in
Auschwitz überhaupt die Systematik der
Vernichtung Auschwitz über eine Million
Juden wurden hier Opfer eines von den
Nazis industriell organisierten
Massenmordes nun stehen die
blockführerärzte und Adjudanten vor
Gericht dank der Hartnäckigkeit des
häsischen Generalstaatsanwalts Fritz
Bauer über 300 Zeugen sagen aus die
meisten von ihnen Auschwitz Überlebende
Gerhard Wiese ist einer der
Staatsanwälte den nun meehr 95-jährigen
empört noch immer dass die Täter während
des gesamten Prozesses kein Wort des
Bedauerns
äußerten nein nein kein R
nein wir hatten immer gehofft dass
wenigstens einer aufsteht und was sagt
aber leider nein sechs Angeklagte werden
zu lebenslanger Haft verurteilt die
meisten bekommen mehrjährige
Freiheitsstrafen oder werden
freigesprochen vor allem aber für die
Auseinandersetzung der deutschen mit dem
Holocaust sind die auschwitzprozesse ein
wichtiger
Schritt jetzt zu einem Mann der sowohl
auf der Bühne als auch im Fernsehen
Zuschauer und Zuhörer begeisterte
Gunther Emmerlich seine Stimme machte
den gebürtigen Thüringer zu einem
gefragten Opernsänger seine offene und
humorige Art zu einem beliebten
Showmaster zuerst im Osten später in
ganz Deutschland gestern starb er
überraschend mit 79 Jahren zu Hause in
Dresden Stefan Kelch
erinnert singen war sein Leben egal wo
egal
wann
[Musik]
Gunther Emmerlich Entertainer im DDR
Fernsehen seine Show die Schokolade nach
1990 steht er als Sänger auf so ziemlich
allen deutschen
Bühnen doch am liebsten sind dem Bass
die Bühnen von Opa und
Operette der gebürtige Thüringer ist für
sein Publikum vor allem der gemütliche
gewante Sachse etwa 300 Tage im Jahr ist
ämerlich unterwegs Stress der Spuren
hinterlässt einen Herzinfarkt erleitet
er mit 63 das vermag zwar seine
Lebensgewohnheiten zu ändern sein
Arbeitspensum hingegen nicht weniger zu
arbeiten das ist nicht geworden aber
aber alles andere was mir der Onkel
Doktor empfohlen hat das beherzige
ich die von Freunden für ihn
organisierte große Party zum 75
Geburtstag erträgt er mit Humor die
Veranstaltung war nicht nur schön
sondern auch ganz schön
lang weil viele und die armen Schweine
mussten mich alle loben ich hätte nicht
in deren Haut stecken wollen vor ein
paar Tagen noch witzelt der
bodenständige Promi über seinen
lieblingsjobter Weihnachtsmann geworden
ja du bist ja der der das rolemodell
quasi von dem Weihnachtsmann also ich
bin der
Weihnacht dieser typische ämerlich Humor
wird
fehlen
so jetzt zum Sport und zur Fußball
Bundesliga und die Sorgen bei Borussia
Dortmund Christin werden immer größer
könnte schöner sein vor Weihnachten die
Lage spitzt sich zu beim BVB durch das
ein Z1 gegen Abstiegskandidat Mainz
Pfeifkonzert auf den Rängen der Abstand
zu den Champions League Plätzen
verschärfte Diskussion um Trainer Edin
tersit bis nach Mitternacht haben sie
hier getagt Geschäftsführer Watzke und
Sportdirektor keh wie es scheint
ergebnislos die Unzufriedenheit der Fans
kurz nach schlussf hörbar denn die
Abwärtsspirale beim BVB setzt sich fort
die Stimmung nach dem Spiel war nicht
gut von uns allen trotzdem haben wir
haben wir uns wieder ehrlich die in die
Augen geschaut es fehlt an Konstanz nur
eine vorzeigbare Halbzeit mit dem
Führungstreffer von Brand nach dem
Anschlusstreffer der Mainzer quasi aus
dem Nichts wirkt der BVB konzeptlos
ideenlos da stehen wir wir wir Jungs die
auf dem Platz stehen plus die die auf
der banks sitzen in in der Verantwortung
weil der Trainer hat die Chance nicht
daneben geschossen auch Sportdirektor
Kehl steht in der Kritik nach nur einem
Sieg in den letzten acht
Partien ja und der Punktgewinn in
Dortmund ermöglicht wohl Interimstrainer
Jan siet eine gute Perspektive in Mainz
Sportdirektor Martin Schmidt sagte
sieard habe das Team mit sieben Punkten
in sieben Spielen stabilisiert er sei in
der
polp erste Saison Niederlage nach Z
Bundesliga spielen für die
volleyballerinen aus Schwerin in einem
spannenden Match in dem die
Schwerinerinnen in gelb bei den
Meisterinnen aus Stuttgart zweimal den
Satz Ausgleich schafften fiel die
Entscheidung im Tiebreak für den MTV am
Ende mit 3:2 Schwerin bleibt aber
Spitzenreiter erstmalig haben vier
deutsche die zweite Runde bei der Darts
WM in London erreicht darunter
Shootingstar Ricardo pitrezko dem ein
souveränes Debüt gelang mit 3:0 gegen
die Japanerin Suzuki die als letzte Frau
dabei war tja immer wieder ein riesen
Spektakel
im danke chr so wir haben noch die
Zahlen vom
Mittwochslotto 4 17 18 25 31 44
Superzahl 9 weitere Gewinnzahlen und
Infos auf
lotto.zdf.de und auf der ZDF Textseite
557 zum Wetter so viel im Harz gilt eine
unw Warnung vor Dauerregen dazu kommt
noch eine sturmlage für ganz Deutschland
Details gleich von östtin terli das
heute journal gibt's um 21:45 Uhr mit
Donja Hayali wir wären für heute durch
sehen uns morgen wieder und wünschen
Ihnen noch einen schönen und entspannten
[Musik]
Abend schön guten Abend und herzlich
willkommen zum Wetter die sturmlage die
sich morgen einstellt die hat es in sich
aus Nordwest kommt das erste tief hier
und bringt ordentlich Wind vor allem an
den Küsten hier teilweise Orkanböhen und
auch in den höheren Lagen Orkanböhen im
Flachland sind 70 bis 100 km pro Stunde
möglich und vor allem bei Gewittern und
Schauern kann es bis nach unten ins
Flachland sogar schwere sturmböhen gehen
aber der Reihe nach es gibt
viel Regen schon in der Nacht und
sturmböhne in den höheren Lagen dazu
auch ergiebigen Regen das ganze wandert
nach Südosten bei tiefsswerten von 0° an
den Alpen und 7° ganz im Westen und
morgen baut sich die sturmlage von
Nordwesten her auf und setzt sich nach
Südosten durch Regen und Schnee sind
dabei viel Schnee in den höheren Lagen
an den Alpen ja und sehr viel Wind eben
orkanböhnen an Küsten und in höheren
Lagen und eben schwere sturmböhen im
Flachland bis 11° ganz im Westen und 5°
an den Alpen die sturmlage ist am
Freitag noch nicht durch weiterhin sehr
viel Wind bei 3 bis 10° und auch am
Samstag gibt es noch keine Entwarnung
und damit einen schönen Abend